[music]
Heat.
Heat. Heat. Heat.
[music]
>> [music]
>> Hello and welcome to another episode of
What's Up Prof.
>> Hello Martin. How are you?
>> [laughter]
>> I'm doing good, thanks. And you?
>> I'm very happy.
>> Yeah. Oh, well, you're very quick as
well. Quick on the draw today.
>> Well, I decided to jump ahead [laughter]
of you this time.
>> Well, I'm glad you're doing well.
>> We are nearing the end of the year.
>> I hope we're nearing the end of this
world
>> time as well. For sure. I think I'm
looking more forward to that than the
end of the year. [laughter]
>> Yes, I think so. If we could if we could
coincide, it would be very good.
>> [laughter]
>> That's a good wish for the season. Um,
but before we begin and jump into this,
maybe we can just take a moment to to
say a thank you to the viewers.
>> I think we need to say a very very big
thank you to all those supporters out
there who have stuck with us, Martin,
through thick and thin.
And I hope we did not disappoint you.
Let's give a little rundown of the
events that have taken place. Martin, we
were privileged to be able to give out
thousands upon thousands of DVDs
and flash drives internationally.
>> Yeah.
>> And we handed out uh thousands upon
thousands of Bibles, 25,000 Bibles.
>> Yeah.
>> Just recently. M
>> and just about the same amount of
conflict of the ages series and
>> great controversies
and uh we've had international lectures
and we've had local lectures and we've
had
>> camp meetings
>> camp meetings and we've had two schools
this year the last one has just been
completed
and uh I think we are all glad that
December is here.
>> Yeah. Yeah.
People that don't know, uh that's our
summer time. So that's why everything
shuts down over December. We will be
closing the official office as well uh
from the
>> 12th of December and it will open up
again on the 12th of January.
>> Yes. But uh we'll still continue
broadcasting and doing everything else
that we do.
And so I just want to say thank you and
a very big thank you to our Lord and
Savior.
Uh you have kept us going. It's been a
rough year.
>> It's been a very rough year, but uh you
have made it possible. You have no idea
how amazing it is that all of these
things can happen because of people
being
uh generous in the way that they are.
They they look at what is being done and
every time there is a need, God just
supplies the need. And we've had the
this not only the school but the health
center running
>> and we've had health center outreaches
in the community
a whole number of them quite a few of
them together with various churches all
over the the country. So we've been very
very busy but very very blessed and I
cannot thank you enough. I cannot thank
our Lord enough and I want to really
from the bottom of our hearts thank all
our viewers and donors for their prayers
for their financial support. It's been
an amazing year. May God bless you all.
>> Yes, thank you very much. We it's
words cannot actually describe
how um people are helping us. And I can
just say that if people want to know
more about orders of the DVDs and flash
drives and other books. We've got your
uh um Sonica, your wife's book as well
still available. They can go onto our
website and there's under the store
area, we've got the international
version there. you can go there and go
and see more of what's available. But um
thank you and God bless all your
endeavors.
>> Yes.
And by the way, I think we can remind
people that in as far as it is humanly
possible, we give these away so that the
message can go out
>> and so that uh people can become
partakers and spread it all around. And
so far God has blessed that venture and
we have been able to do it which is
absolutely a miracle in itself.
>> No, for sure. Maybe also not not
forgetting the translators. We want to
thank them. Wow.
>> We have people that translate as we
produce them. So there are various
languages. I don't even know all the
languages but uh there are many Spanish
and Italian and Portuguese and I think
Russian and maybe even Chinese and
>> I don't even know [laughter] how many
languages
>> and some of these block countries and uh
it's just amazing that uh these are
going out at the same time and these
people are selfless they are doing it
for the cause and for the love of the
cause and so thank you for all of those
translators and may you be richly
blessed in what you are doing.
>> And Martin,
what about the staff working at Clash of
Minds and Varity? May May God bless
them. They've worked hard this year.
>> Look, it won't be possible to run this
these ministries without them.
>> No.
>> So, no,
>> we're very thankful for sure. every
single person
>> from those within the office, from the
IT people, from the therapists,
>> the cooks for the people that are ill
and come to be uh uplifted spiritually
and physically.
>> It's been an amazing team effort.
>> No, for sure.
>> God is very good to us.
>> Thank you everybody. We really
appreciate all your support. Okay,
>> let's pray. Martin.
>> Our heavenly father, thank you for
bringing us together. Thank you for
giving us a year that's passed. And now
that we look to the future, we know that
we cannot put it on or face it without
you. So now also with this discussion,
please guide us and help us in Jesus'
name. Amen.
>> Amen.
Martin, the whole world is buzzing.
>> And in the United States, people are
into the holiday atmosphere.
They're thinking of Thanksgiving
and they're moving into the Christmas
period
and everybody is a buzz.
But I believe that to a very large
extent we've lost the blessed hope.
>> And if I look at some of our churches
and some of our people,
they they don't seem to grasp the
concept that the coming of the Lord is
very near
and that this is the blessed hope of the
church. This has been the blessed hope
for 2,000 years.
Hey Martin, 2,000 years people have been
waiting for this event to take place
>> and so they become complacent and they
say nah the time is not yet and uh it's
rather a sad state of affairs. It's as
as if everybody is in a stuper.
>> Yeah.
>> Some of them realize things are
happening and
>> yeah but
>> but
>> it's not awakening an urgency.
>> It's no urgency. Yeah.
So we have a throne prepared there. That
throne of course is for the king of
kings and lord of lords and not for some
earthly
>> pontificate to go and place themselves
on it pretending to be the king of the
millennium.
>> Yeah,
>> that's not going to happen, right? No,
>> it's not biblical.
And the idea that the whole world will
be converted and Christianized, that the
millennium rule of the church is going
to take place, that uh the Jews will all
return to Palestine. Those are all pipe
dreams that you don't find in the Bible
>> unless you really distort the
scriptures.
>> That's for sure. The only blessed hope
is in Jesus coming and restoring
everything to what it is supposed to.
But he will do it. There's no earthly
king.
>> And [clears throat] the heirs of the
kingdom,
>> Martin, they have been waiting
>> for thousands of years. It's 6,000 years
now, more or less. Well, very close to
that.
>> So, let's jump right into this and see
where it takes us.
The great hope of the ages from the
beginning has been the hope of the
Messiah to set up his kingdom.
But
>> has anybody achieved it up until now?
>> No. And they've been trying
also for millennia.
>> And every time they seem to be, you
know, on the verge, something happens
and it falls apart. Right.
>> Mostly because selfishness and pride
comes in.
>> Correct. And Adam had this hope and
thought it would be realized in one of
his offspring.
>> They probably thought it was going to be
Cain, right?
>> Yeah. Actually, Cain, the first born,
was a murderer.
>> Yes. Now, just imagine that. You're
you're hoping and thinking that this one
that will be born here will redeem and
be the savior and he turns out to be a
murderer. That must have been a terrible
shot. [sighs]
Huh?
>> I think their hearts, Adam and Eve's
hearts,
>> they melted
>> after seeing death of their consequence
in the
>> picture. Yes, absolutely.
>> So, Adam had the hope, Eve had the hope,
but somehow it didn't happen. So, God
strengthened this hope of his when Enoch
was translated, but the Messiah did not
come in his day.
and the anti-dolivian world passed away
and the in destruction rather than in
the glorious kingdom of God.
And if God hadn't intervened at that
last moment, there would have been no
lineage left for the Messiah to come
from.
>> The longsuffering of God to wait till
the very last moment and then he gets
blamed.
>> Yeah.
>> Of genocide, right?
>> Mhm.
>> When actually it was a move to save
humanity right until the end. It's
another move as another another um act
of mercy.
>> Act of mercy. Yes.
>> So God had created man a noble being but
after the fall he had deteriorated and
was in need of redemption. So we read in
Ecclesiastes 7:29.
Lo this only have I found that God has
made man upright.
And then that terrible word but. Yeah,
>> they have thought out many inventions.
>> Yes,
>> man always knows a little bit better.
>> Yeah, that first offspring there of
Cain, they started making the musical
instruments to pervert the sounds that
were in heaven rather than to augment
them. Right.
>> And that's also pulled through right
till today.
>> Yes. Until we have heavy metal today.
[laughter]
Wonder what the angelic host thinks when
they hear that.
It's amazing.
So, Martin, let's continue our little
discussion. This hope lived on in the
post flood world with the promise being
repeated to Noah, Abraham, Isaac, Jacob,
and his descendants, the children of
Israel. And every one of them thought
it's going to happen in their days,
right?
>> And it didn't.
>> No. So modern, how can we be so sure
that we're on the edge?
>> Uh there must be certain things that
have come to fruition.
>> Ah
>> but I must also just say that I don't
think even though it didn't happen in
their day, they never got despondent
about it.
>> No, they kept the hope alive.
>> It was a blessed hope. M so the Jews
they waited for this deliverer fervently
hoping for a national deliverer
and misapplied the prophecies of the
first coming of Christ applying them to
the glorious second coming and thereby
rejected the only one who could save
them. rather sad and
>> very sad.
>> And the words of Jesus, I will come
again. They were the hope of the
Christian church.
>> And the disciples even after the
resurrection asked him at this time, are
you going to set up the kingdom now?
[laughter]
>> It's sad.
>> It's sad that the the the what you want
it to be and what it's going to that's
why you have to get your mindset.
>> You have to get it right. You had to get
in harmony with God.
>> And we're 2,000 years later.
>> I'm glad that the Samaritan,
the good Samaritan only left two
pennies.
>> Yeah.
>> And a penny of course was a day's wages.
And if we look at cosmic days, that
would be 2,000 years wages.
>> Yeah.
>> Now, I'm not time setting. I'm just
quoting the scriptures in case somebody
wants to get all fustipated and confused
again.
>> But there's also not a time setting
because he said if it takes a little bit
more [laughter]
>> then I will compensate.
>> Yes, you're quite right.
>> So it's not to
>> it's not a not a dead end. Yeah. If it
should take a little longer I'll
compensate you for that. Ah amazing.
Okay.
Proverbs 13:12 and 13. Hope deferred
maketh the heart sick.
But when the desire cometh, it is a tree
of life.
>> Uhhuh. So does attitude play a role
here? Ah, it's beautiful. And if your
desire or if your hope is in the wrong
place, you will get your heart sick.
You know what our aim is with this with
this presentation
is to rekindle this hope and to wake up
this
>> come to [laughter] church
wake up
that's true I mean if you don't do it
the desire that cometh you you're not
going to be ready for it
>> no you're not going to be ready who so
despises the word shall be destroyed so
must We study the word.
>> Oh yes.
>> But he that fearth the commandment shall
be rewarded. What
the whole gospel is in that.
>> Yeah.
>> Everything.
>> That is amazing.
>> And it's right there in the Old
Testament.
>> And fear God and keep his commandments.
You get that in Revelation as well.
>> Yes. So for all our brethren and sisters
that say the time is not yet
>> because it's taken so long.
Uh have they studied the scriptures?
Have they studied the word carefully to
see where we are in the stream of time?
We need to perhaps remind them as to why
the situation now is different to what
it was in the time of Adam or Abraham or
Isaac or Jacob or the Israelites or the
early Christian church or the
reformation
etc. Why is it different?
Hagi 2 verse 6 for thus says the Lord of
hosts yet once
it is a little while and I will shake
the heavens and the earth and the sea
and the dry land and I will shake all
nations and the desire of all nations
shall come and I will fill this house
with glory says the Lord of hosts. So he
was declared to be coming.
>> Mhm.
>> This was now the second temple.
>> Yeah.
>> And it was not as glorious as the first
temple.
>> Mhm.
>> But the glory of the second temple which
was not as glorious as the first temple
will exceed the glory of the first
temple because the one who created
everything graced it with his presence.
>> And they they missed it. Right.
>> They missed it. And I it's amazing that
both in Proverbs and in Haggi you get
the desire of all nations.
>> That's the desire of all nations.
>> And a desire of ages has been the same.
>> Now God
>> God so wanted to wake up his church.
Right.
>> Yeah.
>> And so God wanted to wake them up and
shake them up. So he sent the wise men
from the east.
>> Yeah.
>> And he sent them not to Bethlehem. He
sent them to Jerusalem
>> to the king
>> and they went and knocked there and
said, "Excuse me, you guys are the
people of the book. What's happening?
Where's the king?" "What? What king?
King? What king?" [laughter]
>> And Herod heard, "King? King? What
king?"
>> Yeah, I'm the king.
>> I am the king. Okay. So,
he called the the scribes together and
they studied and they said, "He's going
to be born in Bethlehem." But that is so
scary. They actually studied it and they
got to exactly what
>> and none of them went to look.
>> No, they sent them.
>> None of them went to look.
>> They sent them these these eastern wise
men.
>> And so he ignored all the scribes
and he spoke to a couple of shepherds
that were sitting on the field talking
in the night. Right.
>> Yeah.
>> So those are the only ones who
acknowledged his birth.
It's an amazing amazing story and you
know if it weren't so real you would
think it could be a fairy tale
>> but that links on to the scripture where
Jesus asked will I find faith when I
come again?
>> Exactly.
>> It's the same.
>> So Martin although this is a promise of
the first coming
it is just as relevant for the second
coming. Would you agree?
>> Yeah for sure.
This promise was fulfilled to the
letter. In like manner, the promise of
the second coming will also be
fulfilled.
Now they missed it
>> because they had become so complacent
with their rituals.
>> They weren't even looking for him
anymore.
>> So Paul places the shaking of the
heavens and the earth that we're talking
about up here into the future.
>> That's interesting. So there's a double
application to that verse in Hagi.
>> So how does he do that? Where does he do
that? He does this in Romans 12 26 and
27. Whose voice then shook the earth
but now he has promised saying yet once
more I shake not the earth only but also
heaven. And this word yet once more
signifies the removing of those things
that are shaken as the things that are
made that those things which cannot be
shaken may remain.
That's a reference to the second coming.
>> Yeah.
>> So there will be some earthshattering
heavenshaking
events that have taken place and will
take place
>> in order to tell us where we are in the
stream of time. Mhm.
>> Yeah. Some and it's been visible. That's
happened already. In any case, some of
these signs.
>> So, what did they do when the disciples
started preaching this thing? They beat
them up.
>> Yeah. Yes.
>> And what did they do to the people that
started preaching the second coming?
Didn't the churches beat them up, too?
>> Same thing in the 1844,
that period when the first angel's
message went out. and they're still
waiting for their earthly kingdom and
they're working 24/7 to erect it.
>> What's happening to people now preaching
that it's coming soon.
>> But what what happens to all those who
are supposed to be the heirs of the
kingdom? [clears throat]
>> Those that are lying under the ground
dead
>> that were martyrs in the cause of
Christ, many of them. And those that are
waiting for his second coming and want
to do his will so that they may have the
right to enter into the city,
just leave them there. Leave them to
rott another millennia or two or three
so that we can have fun down here.
Right?
>> Makes no sense.
>> So Paul preached the second coming of
Christ
>> with fervor.
Hebrews 6:17, wherein God willing more
abundantly to show unto the heirs of the
promise the immutability of his counsel,
confirmed it by an oath, that by two
immutable things in which it was
impossible for God to lie, we might have
a strong consolation, who have fled for
refuge to lay hold upon the hope set
before us. That's Christ, right?
>> Yeah. Which hope we have as an anchor of
the soul,
>> both sure and steadfast, and which
enterth into that within the veil,
>> whether the forerunner is for us
entered, even Jesus made a high priest
forever after the order of Malchisedc.
So, we've passed that stage in history.
Definitely
>> we've had the fulfillment of the
messianic hope and the types and shadows
of the Old Testament
>> and they've been fulfilled in Christ.
And for what is our hope or joy or crown
of rejoicing? Are not even ye in the
presence of our Lord Jesus Christ at his
coming?
So he was preaching it.
>> Yeah,
>> it's going to happen.
looking for that blessed hope and the
glorious appearing of the great God and
our savior Jesus Christ.
>> Wow,
>> what a statement.
>> That means of course grammatically that
Jesus Christ is the great God and is the
savior.
>> That's what I mean. Oh man, I don't want
to even go there, but you cannot just
throw this verse out of the Bible, can
you? But it's 2,000 years now.
>> I'm getting tired. I'm going to go to
sleep.
>> It sounds like Peter and the rest of
them when Jesus went to pray.
>> Yeah. Soon they will be celebrating New
Year and everybody will try to remain
awake until 12:00.
>> But the greatest event of history and
everybody will be snoozing.
>> There has to be a wakeup call.
>> Correct.
>> And hopefully we can start one.
>> I hope so. I hope so. Paul was sustained
by this hope. They warned others that
they should not expect it before the
great falling away had done its bailful
work.
>> So they were saying, you know, Christ is
going to come. It's going to come in our
age. Are you The disciples had said, are
you going to set it up now or in the
next generation or this generation? You
know, whatever. Thessalonians, let no
man deceive you by any means, for that
day shall not come except there come a
falling away first and the man of sin be
revealed, the son of petition. Whoa,
Martin. Historically, has that happened?
>> Yes.
>> Who revealed the man of sin?
>> The reformation.
>> Oh, that's quite a few years ago
already.
>> Yes. That's just a little over 500 years
ago, right?
>> Yeah. And the reformers preached it
fervently.
>> Yeah.
>> And the descendants of the reformers
have canned it and thrown it into the
waste paper basket, joined the
ecumenical movement and forgot who the
man of sin was.
>> That's also no forming part of the
falling away. These other churches as
well.
>> Okay. So the falling away has happened
>> and the man of sin has been revealed
>> and that man of sin is going to be
destroyed by the brightness of the of
the Lord's coming.
>> Yeah.
>> All right. So I'm just trying to
establish a stream through history here
>> to see where we are.
>> To see where we are. Isn't it important
to know where we are?
>> Of course.
>> Okay. Who opposes and exalts himself
above all that is called God or that is
worshiped. So that he as God sits in the
temple of God showing himself that he is
God. So there he sits in the temple of
God which is the church and not a temple
of stone as the reformers taught
>> pretending to be God. And all of those
papal statements that claim that the
papacy is God and all those ancient
documents cannot be denied
>> unless you want to do it to your own
demise.
>> Yeah.
So that has been revealed. But this I
confess unto thee, that after the way
which they call heresy.
>> So worship I the God of my fathers,
believing all things which are written
in the law and the prophets. Martin, I
believe the Bible.
>> Yeah.
>> And I believe you believe the Bible
>> completely.
>> Completely. Every single word, all
things.
>> Okay. But then we qualify to be
fanatics.
>> Yes. And fundamentalists.
>> And fundamentalist.
>> I'm a very happy fundamentalist.
>> All right. And now just [snorts]
day or two ago, I can't remember. Quite
recently, the new pope also said
away with all fanatics fundamentalists.
>> Oh, he did.
>> Well, I'm very happy because that's
another sign of the times.
>> Are we then heretics?
Oh yes, Martin. Uh in according to them,
we're heretics because we believe the
word, namely all things that are written
in the law and the prophets.
>> So we agree with Paul here that
according to their description of a
heretic, we qualify.
>> I'm a very happy heretic as far as that
is concerned. So what do we have Martin?
We have hope towards God, which they
themselves also allow. that there shall
be a resurrection of the dead, both of
the just and the unjust. And herein do I
exercise myself to have always a
conscience void of offense towards God
and towards men. So he had this blessed
hope that all of these
minations and events that will take
place, they will pass by in history, but
eventually
everything will culminate in the coming
of Christ.
And Peter, did he have the same hope?
>> Yep, for sure.
>> Blessed be the God and Father of our
Lord Jesus Christ, which according to
his abundant mercy has begotten us again
unto a lively hope by the resurrection
of Jesus Christ from the dead,
to an inheritance incorruptible,
undefiled, that fadeth not away,
reserved in heaven for you. So where
where's this reward, Martin?
>> Not here.
>> Okay. Who are kept by the power of God
through faith unto salvation, ready to
be revealed when?
>> In the last time.
>> In the last time. So you can set up your
kingdoms as much as you like. Uh it's
not going to float.
>> No.
When ye greatly rejoice, though now for
a season, if need be, you are in heaven
through manifold temptation, that the
trial of your faith, being much more
precious than of gold that perishes,
though it be tried with fire, might be
found unto praise and honor and glory,
when
>> at
>> the appearing of Jesus Christ, not at
the setting up of a temporal millennium
by a bunch of churches that would deny
the saints of all ages to be part of the
kingdom.
>> No,
>> doesn't make any sense.
>> So, in the light of what we've just
read, is Christ lacks in his coming
or is there some fixed protocol?
>> Yes, I believe there is.
He set the boundaries for humanity and
he granted them the opportunity to find
him and be saved until such time as the
redeemed of all ages should be gathered
and become the children of the kingdom.
>> Does that make sense?
>> Yes. So not being gathered and enter the
kingdom here and live on this night.
>> It doesn't matter what you believe.
>> God will sort out the doctrines when we
get upstairs. I'm terribly sorry. They
have to be sorted out here because they
were written down in a book.
>> And take heed of the doctrine, says the
Bible. And the Pope says, "Set it
aside." One of the two is lying.
>> Yep. And I don't [clears throat] believe
the Bible is. So,
>> no. John 1:10. He was in the world and
the world was made by him, and the world
knew him not. He came unto his own, and
his own received him not.
But fortunately, there's another butt
here which is a positive butt this time.
As many as received him, to them he gave
power to become the sons of God, even to
them that believe on his name.
This power is the outpouring of the Holy
Spirit upon God's children.
So Martin the Israel of all ages
they will be heirs of the kingdom
whether they were the literal
people or the spiritual heirs right
>> yeah it's interesting that the the same
requirements to qualify to be part of
Israel has been same for the old ones
and for the spiritual ones
>> yes Deuteronomy 32:8 when the most high
divided the nations their inheritance
when he separated ated the sons of Adam.
He separated them. He set the bounds of
the people according to the number of
the children of Israel. For the Lord's
portion is his people. Jacob is the lot
of his inheritance. So they divide it
into two streams. The stream of Cain
>> and the stream of Adam through Seth and
Shem etc.
>> Just to Okay. So the separation what did
that cause? What did Cain's people do
and Cain?
>> They developed the religion of the east
which was a religion facing away from
the sanctuary, away from the atonement
of Christ, away from the altar.
>> They set their their compass upon
salvation through their own works.
>> Yeah. So and the other ones were keeping
the commandments of God.
>> Yes. always been the same requirements.
>> Same requirements.
So this is the Israel of all ages, the
overcomers who have wrestled with God
since the beginning.
>> When this purpose has been realized, his
people shall be all clothed with the
robe of righteousness. They constitute
the heirs of the kingdom. So from the
earliest times, whether we're talking
about Enoch, whether we're talking about
Noah, whether we're talking about
Matusalem, or whether we're talking
about the post flood people, the line of
Shem and Jaffet and Ham, whether we're
talking about the division that took
place there where they separated again,
those following the line of Nimrod
>> and those following the line of the
Lord's people Abraham, Isaac, and Jacob
always been two groups.
>> Always.
And this robe of righteousness, you will
be clothed with the robe of
righteousness.
>> That's the only robe that'll get you
into heaven.
>> And it's definitely not your own.
>> No, it's definitely an alien
righteousness. So Isaiah 60:21 says,
"Thy people also shall be all righteous.
[clears throat]
>> They shall inherit the land forever. the
branch of my planting, the work of my
hands, that I may be glorified. That's
his kingdom from the beginning to the
end. But it hasn't been realized yet
because they're lying under the ground.
They're sleeping.
Mhm.
Second Peter said, "The Lord is not
slack concerning his promise, as some
may count slackness, but is
longsuffering to us with, not willing
that any should perish, but that all
should come to repentance."
The kingdom is pressing in. It is
growing.
>> That's why we are sometimes a little bit
selfish because we wanted to come now.
>> Right now, I certainly wanted to come.
We have to be longsuffering.
>> So, is it a fable?
>> Uh, well,
>> there many that start believing.
>> How many?
>> Oh, the Lord delays his coming. So, I'll
be eating and drinking and parting and
you know, I've got lots of time left.
>> Yeah. Yeah.
So Peter says, "For we have not followed
cunningly devised fables when we made
known unto you the power and coming of
our Lord Jesus Christ, but were
eyewitnesses of his majesty."
>> So when Christ will come when the
prophecies concerning his coming have
been fulfilled, would you agree with
that?
>> I agree 100% with that. There's no
nothing waiting. He's not waiting. He's
waiting for the prophecies to be
fulfilled. Were the Old Testament
prophecies of his first coming fulfilled
>> up until the hour or the minute?
>> Absolutely.
This day, this prophecy has been
fulfilled in your hearing.
>> Hey, when it came out of the waters of
baptism, the time is fulfilled. What
time? The time of Daniel, right?
the the 70we prophecy
which ended when modern in 27
>> AD
>> AD add 2,000 to that
>> I don't mathematics is not the strong
point of many of our scribes and
Pharisees so let's not confuse them with
adding those dates to show where we are
in the stream of time not when he's
coming just where we are in the stream
of time
>> okay
>> it's the same when Jesus said, "Look at
that fig tree." He wasn't setting a
specific, but he was showing you,
listen, this thing is not ready, so get
out of here.
>> Yep. So, Martin, when the prophecies are
all fulfilled, then he will be coming,
right?
>> Yep.
>> Is it important to know how many of
these prophecies have been fulfilled?
>> Exactly. That's the way that's that's
how you count and that's where your
timeline lies. What? How did the wise
men
know that there was going to be a
Messiah coming?
>> They were studying the prophecies.
>> Daniel's prophecies.
>> Yes. The 70we one.
>> Yes. They came from the Meersian ancient
religious systems that had had honored
the writings of Daniel. Exactly. More
sometimes than those that were supposed
to be Yep.
>> the harborers of the oracles. Right.
So if prophecy is to be interpreted in
the light of history,
only historic continuous interpretation
of prophecy can do justice to all ages.
>> Mhm.
>> I mean this nonsense about futurism
where all prophecies are fulfilled at a
time when the church is not even here.
What's the point of writing the Bible
then? I don't know why anybody can
believe such nonsense.
>> But they're all running with it, right?
But I think
>> sensationalism.
>> I think maybe there's a little bit of an
ease to it because you're still waiting
and waiting and putting it off because
certain things has not come but they're
looking at the wrong
>> Yes.
>> They're looking at the wrong map and
they're looking at the wrong events.
>> You're going to end up and the compass
is wrong. So you're going to end up in
the wrong place.
>> Yes. So all ages had to study the
scriptures to see where they are in the
stream of time.
And had humanity, if humanity had
diligently studied the prophecies in
this context, they would not have grown
weary in waiting and suffered shipwreck
of their faith.
>> And I believe many of our people are
doing exactly the same thing. So the
prophecies of Daniel and Revelation need
to be understood because they give us
the great lines of history plus the
events that are to occur before the
great and terrible day of the Lord. We
need to know what's happening there.
So Daniel delineated it and it has been
fulfilled to the letter.
>> Mhm.
Revelation gives us the blueprint,
but multitudes have no idea as to what
will transpire. It is as though it never
been written. They say it's a closed
book.
>> And
it is sad.
>> The Lord exposed the fallacy that
prophecy cannot be understood in Isaiah,
Daniel, and Revelation are one.
>> Yeah. So Isaiah says, "You must
understand the prophecies."
And without Daniel, you will not
understand what's going on in
Revelation. You'll just have weird
beasts.
>> Yeah.
>> So Daniel is the key and the other is
the revelation.
Let's look at these timelines to see
where we are in the stream of times. So
let's look at this verse in these verses
in Isaiah chapter 29 onwards. Thou shalt
be visited of the Lord of hosts with
thunder and with earthquake and great
noise, with storm and tempest and the
flame of devouring fire. That's pretty
>> ominous, right? And the multitude of all
the nations that fight against Ariel.
>> Yeah,
>> we'll deal with that in a moment. Mhm.
>> Even all that fight against her and her
munitions and that distress her shall be
as a dream of a night vision.
It shall even be as when a hungry man
dreameth, and behold he eateth, but he
awaketh and his soul is empty. Or as
when a thirsty man dreameth, and behold
he drinkketh, but he awaketh, and behold
he is faint.
And his soul has appetite,
so shall the multitudes of the nations
be that fight against Mount Zion. So
those that fight against Jerusalem
in its literal sense or in its spiritual
sense
>> will actually be starving, hungry and
thirsting for something that they do not
know about.
>> Literal was what happened.
>> Yes,
>> spiritual is what is happening.
>> Yes.
Stay [snorts] yourselves and wonder. Cry
ye out and cry. They are drunken but not
with wine. They stagger but not with
strong drink. They stagger with false
doctrines.
>> For the Lord has poured out upon you the
spirit of deep sleep.
>> We there.
>> This is a very contagious sleep.
>> It's a pandemic of sleep.
>> And has closed your eyes. The prophets
and your rulers, the seers has he
covered. And the vision of all is become
unto you as the words of a book that is
sealed.
>> Oh, revelation is a sealed book. Nobody
needs to go there.
>> But it's a revelation.
>> It's a revelation. Yes. Which men
deliver to one that is learned, saying,
"Read this. I pray thee." And he says,
"I cannot do this. You see your
[laughter]
>> is exactly what's happening."
>> Yeah.
I I know I'm laughing but
>> No, but it's it's a tragedy because
unfortunately it's true. I'm I
understand why you're laughing because
wow, okay, this is actually happening.
You realize it
>> exactly what happened.
>> And what can you do to wake the people
up?
>> Nothing. Nothing. And an atom bomb won't
wake them up. So let's have a look at a
little bit further. Verse 12. And the
book is delivered to him that is not
learned. Uhhuh.
>> So the learned guy says, "Oh, I don't
know what's going on here.
>> Read this, I pray thee." And he says,
"I'm not learned. I cannot do this."
>> So it's not my fault. The scribe should
be telling me what's going on. Right?
Wherever the Lord says, "For as much as
this people draw near me with their
mouth and with their lips to honor me,
but have removed their heart far from
me, and their fear towards me is taught
by the precepts of men." They they don't
study this stuff.
>> So even if you not learn it, you can
still study it. God will help.
>> So they're making up their religion as
they go along.
>> So Martin, if you don't understand what
the book says, wouldn't it be nice to
have about six drum sets to make a lot
of noise to make up for the lack of
knowledge?
>> Sure, you can repeat some things over
and over and over and over.
Therefore, behold, I will proceed to do
a marvelous work amongst this people,
even a marvelous work and a wonder. For
the wisdom of their wise men shall
>> perish, and the understanding of their
prudent men shall be hid. It's a very
big warning. So, who is this Ariel?
>> This Ariel is a symbolic name for
Jerusalem, meaning lion of God. M
>> the verse describes the multitudes of
nations that will fight against
Jerusalem and the name Ariel emphasizes
the city's significance as a both a
place of divine power and a target for
God's judgment.
Ariel means the lion of God in Hebrew,
referencing the city's strength and its
divine protection. Now, we're looking at
it in a spiritual sense.
>> Yeah.
because literal Jerusalem
was destroyed in 70 AD. Yes, it's been
rebuilt and they're trying to uh rebuild
the temple, which is a blasphemy because
the temple has no value anymore
whatsoever because the lamb of God that
taketh away the sins of the world has
been sacrificed and he has become the
high priest of a better temple of which
the bottom one, the earthly one was
merely a copy, a symbol.
So Martin all those that fight against
the truth
>> will be
in this category of people that do not
know what is going on. So let's just
have a brief look at what has happened.
Daniel gave us the stream of time and
told us what kingdoms would succeed each
other. And there was the head of gold
which was Babylon.
>> Yeah.
>> And in Daniel chapter 7 it was the lion
with eagle's wings.
>> Come and gone.
>> Gone.
>> Meo [clears throat] Persia.
He tells us what it is. We don't
>> you can read it there. Which kingdoms
and what's going on there.
>> And there was the bear of Daniel chapter
and come and gone. Mhm.
>> Then there were the hips of brass, which
is the foreheaded
leopard beast in Daniel chapter 7. Come
and gone. That's Greece.
>> Then the iron of Rome, the terrible
beast.
>> Yeah.
>> That would break up into 10 components,
the European states, the 10 horns.
>> And the iron of Rome, pagan Rome, is
gone. It had two legs, the eastern and
the western empire. Then it broke up
into the 10 tribes of Europe, the 10
horns and their
ruling.
>> Yeah. Well, trying to
>> Now, we pick up this story. We pick up
this story in Revelation
and we get a number of interesting
points. So, the beasts of Revelation are
fascinating because a beast is a
kingdom. how it is operated. Right? So
in Revelation chapter 11, you have the
beast from the bottomless pit.
>> And it tells us that this beast of the
bottomless pit is the one that will
attack God's people here at the end of
time. Right at the end of time. And then
we get a little bit of detail as to how
all of these beasts came into existence
and where they are now and who's gone
and who's not gone and who's doing what
and to whom.
>> So in Revelation 12, we have a red
dragon with seven heads and crowns on
his heads.
>> And we are told in Revelation 12 that
this dragon would attack even the prince
of the covenant,
>> Jesus. and would kill him and then it
would make war against
God's people in another form and
eventually in another form make
[clears throat]
war against those that keep the
commandments of God and hold to the
testimony of Jesus. Right?
>> So that's in Revelation 12 talking about
pagan Rome that attacked the early
church,
>> persecuted it. That's the time of
>> Smyrna,
>> the church of the persecution
that pagan Rome persecuted. And then it
changed to papal Rome.
>> So in Revelation chapter 13, we have the
conglomerate beast that consists of all
of the features that we have over here
in Daniel chapter 7. All of these are
incorporated into one. So it's a little
bit of Babylonian, a little bit of Meo
Persian, a little bit a lot of a lot of
uh Greek because that's the body of it
and it has Meo Persian aspects and it
has the 10 horns and the crowns have
shifted to the horns.
>> So this is the time period when the
church of Rome ruled through the powers
of Europe,
>> the 1,260day
period. Has it come and gone?
>> Yes, it's gone. It's actually gone. A
long time gone already.
>> Yes. And then Martin, there's another
beast that arises in Revelation chapter
13 that had two horns and it had
lamblike principles,
>> but it actually spoke like this other
terrible beast eventually, right?
>> And we know that that is the rise of the
United States of America,
>> that had lamblike principles.
and uh
Protestantism.
>> Yes, it
>> number one. And Republicanism.
>> Yeah.
>> So those two horns would eventually come
together and emulate this terrible beast
of Revelation 13 that symbolized the
little horn power of Daniel chapter 7
that would change times and laws and
persecute God's people.
>> Mhm.
>> Right. and make war against those that
uh keep the commandments.
So in Revelation chapter 17, we have a
scarlet sevenheaded beast with no
crowns.
So Martin asked AI
to come up with a picture and this is
what they came up with. It took a couple
of tries to get a beast like this. So
here was the woman uh the colors scarlet
and purple are quite prominent.
>> Mhm.
>> And she assumes royalty, right?
>> And she assumes the sacrificial system,
the blood.
>> And she has a cup in her hand full of
the filthiness of her fornication, her
false doctrines, [clears throat]
her false wine that she passes out to
everyone. And Martin, there are no
crowns anywhere on this beast.
>> So this beast is the period between 1798
>> Yeah.
>> when she lost her crowns
and today.
>> Yeah.
>> Right.
>> It's pretty late in the prophecy already
with everything that has already been
fulfilled.
>> All right. So Martin all of these in
Daniel
>> have been fulfilled.
All of these in Daniel chapter 7 have
been fulfilled. The ruling the details
of who they are and when they ruled have
been fulfilled.
The beast from the bottomless pit.
This philosophy Martin comes from this
woman.
>> Mhm. From the doctrines and all of that.
And she's riding this beast that doesn't
have any kings at the moment. That's
where we are now in the streams of
history. Right.
>> Yeah.
>> And Martin,
she is ruling. The Bible tells us in the
time period in which we are now living
clandestinely under the radar.
>> Mhm.
>> There's no crown there, but she's
ruling.
>> Yeah.
>> And she's dictating.
>> She's in the shadow. The second beast of
Revelation 13 is going to do her
bidding.
>> Mhm.
>> And they're going to give power unto
that beast. And they're going to enforce
her mark. Are we in that time period?
>> Yeah.
>> What are we waiting for?
>> What great event is going to happen? Is
there going to be another beast, another
kingdom arising after this?
>> No.
>> Well, in Revelation chapter 17, it says
there will be a little bit of a
resurrection. M
>> and this power that is actually ruling
here a crownless
>> empire world empire
is going to become the eighth.
>> He's going to emulate Christ. It's going
to be the resurrection of the papacy
when his mark is enforced and his law
again becomes paramount in the world.
But that's the last event we're waiting
for. nothing else.
And it's being fulfilled right before
our eyes. And what will it take to wake
up the snoring church? [snorts]
[laughter]
>> A shake. Like I said, I don't know. We
have to get a shaking going.
>> All of this has been fulfilled.
>> There's nothing left. Nothing.
>> I've heard that the church has to be
perfect before Jesus can come. So, I was
thinking that was what we're waiting
for. How about how perfect was Enoch
when he was translated?
>> Well, he didn't have any spot or
wrinkle.
>> Really?
>> Yes.
>> What about Elijah?
>> The same.
>> But he was a man with like passions unto
us. The Bible says,
>> of course. So Martin uh all those uh
reformers
that lived up to the light that they had
to the point of death even the death at
the stake.
>> What robe did they have on?
>> The same one that everybody will have on
to make it to heaven.
>> How perfect was that robe?
>> Perfect. Because it's only one that can
be perfect.
>> Okay. So can you supersede perfection?
Can you be more perfect than they?
>> No.
I believe salvation has been the same
throughout all ages. The only difference
>> is what I said. You have to live up to
the light that you have.
>> And unfortunately, this we've got quite
a bit of light by now.
>> We have more light than any of them. Did
Martin Luther know who the second beast
of Revelation 13 was?
>> No.
>> Hadn't even been discovered yet.
>> Exactly.
>> He didn't know. He didn't know. Did he
know about the woman riding the beast?
Yes, he knew who the woman was.
>> Yeah. Yeah. But he couldn't know the
beast yet.
>> But he could he have known who the beast
without horn without crowns was?
>> No.
>> No. He couldn't have known that. He
couldn't have known that. Martin
>> see this all
this is why I think if people are
waiting for certain things that we have
to do
then we can go into a snoring state
>> ready or not here I come is going to
happen sooner or later. God is not
dependent upon us. We are dependent upon
him lest we become presumptuous. We can
hasten
the coming if we do his will and we do
our job and we wake up the people.
>> You know, Martin, it would have been
possible to go home many a times if
Israel had accepted the Messiah.
>> It could have been over
>> if the early advent movement had
accepted the doctrine of righteousness
by faith. We could have gone home.
So shall I say fortunately or
unfortunately they didn't live up to the
light which they received.
>> Yes. Unfortunately for a lot of people
but fortunately for us
>> fortunately for us. So Martin let's just
discuss this a little bit. So this
delineation of the final event
culminating in the abomination of
desolation
standing in the holy place as prophesied
in the book of Daniel.
This follows the flow of history
outlined in the book of Revelation.
Isn't that so?
>> Yeah.
>> So, the beast out of the bottomless pit
that wars against the word of God and
against his people has certain phases.
>> The first phase of this terrible beast
with dragon attributes confronted the
living word himself and the early
church. That's what we read in
Revelation 12.
>> Yeah.
This was pagan Rome with crowns on the
seven heads and had swallowed up all the
kingdoms listed by Daniel.
As we march on through time, we come to
the same Roman power where the crowns
had shifted to the 10 horns of
Revelation 13
>> where the horn of Daniel 7 ruled for
1,260
years. He changed times. He changed
laws. He persecuted the saints. [snorts]
>> He spoke blasphemous words. He assumed
to forgive sins. He assumed to be God on
earth. It was a terrible situation
until he seemed to have received a
mortal wound and morphed into the beast
of Revelation 17.
>> Mhm.
>> Now he's underground.
>> Yeah.
>> Where his secular power has apparently
been removed
>> symbolized by the absence of crowns.
>> So now how's he ruling? He's ruling in
secret through secret societies.
>> Yeah.
>> Through Knights of Columbus and Knights
of Malta, the Jesuits,
you name all of these diabolical groups
that uh rule Clander Steinley, the
Masons, and the Rosacruians and all
their occult nonsense. Mhm.
>> So he morphed into this beast of
Revelation 17 where his secular power
had apparently been removed symbolized
by the absence of crowns. But she still
controlled the beast because the church
rides the beast
>> while holding the cup with her
abominations and intoxicating the world
with its contents. So how does she
control the beast? That's a valid
question for sure.
Well, she controls it through her
proxies.
>> We've read a lot about proxies.
>> Even in, you know, world governments.
Yes. Whether you call them Hamas or
Hezbollah or whatever, these are all
proxies so-called of someone else.
>> Exactly. Some bigger or something
someone behind.
>> Correct.
>> That wants their things. So through her
proxies and secret minations and by
using the second beast of Revelation 13
until her purposes should be
accomplished and the union of church and
state again be restored.
Are we in that process?
>> It's right there. We are this. And where
is this going to be the most prevalent
first?
The beast.
>> Yes.
>> United States. That's where we are
looking at.
>> That's where we're looking at. We're not
looking at turkey.
>> No.
>> No. In fact, it was it was just
Thanksgiving and one of the turkeys has
been exonerated and pardoned by Donald
Trump. So, we're not looking at turkeys.
They [laughter] have been pardoned.
>> I see that the pope also his first visit
since he's became pontiff was to Turkey.
Now,
>> did he have a Thanksgiving turkey as
well? I don't know.
>> Probably went to Thanksgiving. I hope he
had it with
>> you. We've visited a lot of the
churches, the Orthodox church, and they
are in ecumenical council. So, it's
going very well.
>> We're going to set aside this rift
that's been there for over a thousand
years. Okay.
So she's using proxies
and the union of church and state is to
be restored. Creating the image that
does her bidding, enforces her mark and
makes war against Christ and his truth
by pers persecuting his children that
keep the commandments and hold to the
testimony of Jesus. modern. Everything's
been done and they're talking about this
union of church and state
>> and setting up this
kingdom.
>> Yeah. The Christian nationalists have
made it very clear what they want.
>> They know we've had discussions with
them so much. And aren't we right there?
>> Yeah. Is there anything else that we
could possibly have missed in the book
of Revelation that still has to come to
make this thing continue for another
millennium or two?
>> Only misinterpretation. That's the only
thing if you are reading in and putting
things there that's not flowing into the
rest of it.
>> All right. So, has the first form of the
beast with crowns and heads come and
gone?
>> Yes.
The second one with crowns on the horns.
[snorts]
>> Yes.
Okay. The third with no crowns.
>> Is the second beast out of the earth
here?
>> Yes.
>> Is it setting up the image by uniting
church and state?
>> Open your eyes. You can see it right
now. Yes.
>> Is the mark of the first beast on his
agenda?
>> For sure. Is it written into the
document 2025?
>> Absolutely.
>> Is it written there? Right. Yes.
Have we marched through the stream of
time to the imminent fulfillment of the
prophecies of the book of Revelation?
>> There's nothing left.
>> Nothing.
>> Then why have the children become weary
of waiting and have fallen into a stuper
when they should be wide awake now? All
right. So when the time of the
fulfillment of the prophecy has arrived,
it will be fulfilled. It has always been
thus and it will be like this again
because the apostles Peter says in 2
Peter 1:19, we have also a more sure
word of prophecy where unto you do well
that you take heed. By the way,
the whole world that sort of denigrates
this book and from the very first pages
in this book, you know, make it a
laughing stock and a fairy tale when
they look at this,
shouldn't they fall over and have an
epiplectic fit because of their
ignorance? No. Because there's so many
voices out there and they don't test the
word. They just listen to all these
other things and say, "Oh, this is just
part of the whole box and dice."
>> So, has this actually confirmed
prophecy, all of these things that have
happened?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. So, would we do well to take heed
as unto a light that shines in a dark
place
>> until the day dawn and the day star
arise in your hearts?
>> You have to let Jesus do that. He has to
kindle that fire that has to wake up.
All right, let's muse a little further.
So Jesus told us himself and informed
these prophets to tell us what would
transpire, right? There would be a
falling away. It happened.
The dark ages, papal Rome,
>> there would be a reformation where the
persecuted church in the wilderness
would come out of Babylonian captivity.
>> Mhm.
>> Get out of happen. Martin Luther said
that there would be a war against the
word of God as recorded in Revelation
chapter 11
[clears throat]
>> and that all happened. We had evolution.
We had Marxism. We just removed God from
the equation and we set up uh this
liberty
that we have in the world.
>> And even the word
>> liberty
>> to do whatever you want.
>> Yeah. For sure. And even the scriptures
have been infiltrated in the other
>> manuscripts.
>> So the word would be raised above heaven
and earth and all would have access to
it. We had the Bible societies giving
the word out and doctrines of devils and
false manifestations of false spirits
would try to destroy it. It's happening
all over the world. the everlasting
gospel would again be preached and
restored in the first angel's message
resulting in the fall of Babylon because
they wouldn't accept it. No, they want a
temporal millennium. They want the Jews
to go back to Palestine and they want
the whole world to be converted when the
Bible says no, there will be sheep and
there will be goats.
>> Yeah.
>> So, they're living in a fool's paradise.
Okay.
and will culminate in the final
persecution. Have these events all taken
place and we're now heading for this
final persecution?
>> Yeah, we're right there.
>> So, if so, why have we become paralyzed
instead of energized?
>> Hopefully, this can help a little bit.
>> Martin, don't fall asleep, please.
Prophecy tells us that the coming of the
Lord will come as a thief in the night
to the children of unbelief.
That's the main thing. They totally
distort that one with a secret rapture.
All right. So, the churches
that are not longing for the coming of
Christ, but longing for some earthly
event to take place here.
They are heading for a thief in the
night experience.
So Thessalonians chapter 5 tells us,
"For yourselves know perfectly that the
day of the Lord so come as a thief in
the night.
For when they shall say peace and
safety, you when Ukraine finally has
peace and Jerusalem has peace and uh you
know
>> then then it will be fine.
>> Venezuela comes into line.
>> Mhm.
>> Let's have a look. Then sudden
destruction comes upon them as travail
upon a woman with child, and they shall
not escape. But ye, brethren, are not in
darkness that that day should overtake
ye as a thief. So modern, we're not
supposed to be in a thief of a night
experience
because you are children of the light.
You have the light and the light is the
Bible, isn't it?
>> Yeah.
>> And the children of the day. We are not
of the night nor of darkness because we
can read what it says in Revelation. And
we don't believe that it's a closed
book. Like Isaiah said, the scribes and
the Pharisees will say, "Oh, I'm I don't
know what that means."
>> So, let us not sleep as do others, but
let us watch and be sober. For they that
sleep in the night. They're in darkness
because they don't follow the light.
>> No.
And they that be drunken are drunken in
the night. But let us who are of the day
be sober, putting on the breastplate of
faith and love for the helmet the hope
of salvation. Martin, we have no need to
be in darkness.
It's again going back to selfishness and
pride. That's most of the times God is
not slack in giving you the light.
>> How many people are actually with fire
preaching that the Lord's coming is at
the door? It's a handful.
>> It's a handful, but it should be
millions.
>> Don't get despondent by people that tell
you, "Ah, you're fearongering." [snorts]
Don't waste your time listening to them.
Carry on.
>> In reviewing our past history, having
traveled over every step of advance to
our present standing, I can say, "Praise
God." As I see what God has wrought, I'm
filled with astonishment and with
confidence in Christ as leader. We have
nothing to fear for the future except as
we shall forget the way the Lord has led
us and his teachings in our past
history. You know, Martin, I'm I'm
working on a sermon about two
invitations to the wedding feast.
>> Yeah.
>> One is in Matthew and the other one is
in Luke. Mhm.
>> Now, the one in Matthew is fascinating
because it specifically says there
that uh they are invited to dinner.
>> Okay.
>> Invited to dinner, Martin. So, if you
look up that word dinner, it means the
first meal of the day. Breakfast. Oh,
breakfast. Now, wedding has changed a
little bit over the ages, but you have
to go and check it out in the original
Greek and it means the first meal of the
day. There was an invitation to come to
the wedding and to come to the
breakfast.
>> Okay.
>> That invitation went out to the Jews.
>> Mhm.
>> To accept the Messiah who was the
bridegroom who was amongst the people.
>> Yeah.
>> Right.
And then there's a second one in Luke
where it is an invitation to the supper.
>> It's a different Greek word. It's the
last meal of the day.
>> So that invitation was not for the Jews.
>> The last one after
>> that one came later. It came after 1844
or during that time period
>> when the Millerites preached that Christ
is coming
>> and everything is now made ready and the
churches rejected it and mocked the
people that had studied the prophecies
of Daniel.
>> That was the the midnight cry that went
out that the bridegroom is coming.
>> Yes. It was a wedding invitation to the
supper.
>> The supper call has gone out. It has
dissipated. The signs that were to
preeded
the dark day
>> 1780 just before the end of the 1,260
days. Then the the pouring out of the
the stars that fell. That was 1833.
just before that period of 1844 a
preparation the signs in heaven even
that has all been fulfilled what are we
waiting for
>> I think we've also had a mini parallel
>> in the last 5 years of behold the
bridegroom cometh
>> yes
>> and get ready get ready get ready
>> correct correct but everybody went back
to sleep again
>> right after that I mean now they're
snoring even louder than they did 5
years ago
>> yes so Martin if We look at this history
and the churches,
they rejected this call that Christ was
coming. They wanted to stick to their
creed,
>> their little creed that they were going
to set up the kingdom. Forget about all
the heirs of the kingdom. They're not
going to get it. We're going to get it.
Right?
>> Nowhere in the Bible do you read that?
So Aminier in his history of the
reformation says God who prepared his
work through ages accomplishes it by the
weakest instruments when his time has
come to affect great results by the
smallest means such is the law of God.
This law which prevails everywhere in
nature is also found in history.
So the world's great men were passed by.
>> Mhm.
>> And the heirs were the shepherds and the
highways and the byways people. And
those that were invited,
they had other things to do. They had
bought a piece of land. They had, you
know, married someone. They had done
something else. Whatever.
So what the Lord promised the Israelites
was fulfilled in detail. First Kings
8:56 says, "Blessed be the Lord that has
given rest unto his people Israel
according to all that he has promised.
There has not failed one word of all his
good promise which he promised by the
hand of Moses his servant." Can't we say
the same about the book of Revelation?
>> Exactly the same. And we can see so much
that has been promised that has been
fulfilled.
>> Yes. So the same applies to the New
Testament era. Second Peter says in 1:4,
"Whereby are given to us exceeding great
and precious promises, that by these ye
may be partakers of the divine nature,
having escaped the corruption that is in
the world through lust. For all the
promises of God, Paul says in
Corinthians, in him are yay, in him,
amen, unto the glory of God by us." If
this book,
if this book
has not authenticated itself by now in
the minds of men, it never will.
>> No,
it's all there. It's everything is there
and it's a choice. You still you can
decide and you can see because the proof
is also there. somebody that wants to
work on facts and proof. There's enough
in the Bible to show you through
prophecy being fulfilled 100% the proof.
>> Yes.
>> Of how came to fruition.
>> Were the pre the reformers prepared to
die for what they believed?
>> Shouldn't we be prepared to die for what
we believed?
>> Absolutely.
>> So truth is worth dying for. Martin, let
us rehearse the history of truth
uncovered in the martyrdom of those who
stood for it. From Wickliffe to Hus to
Luther, the great reformers to the
Anabaptists
such as Hunts Hoot, Menos Simons,
Oswwell Glate, the Sabotarians, the
Baptist, the Congregationalists, the
Methodists, the Seventh Day Baptist, the
Millerites, the Christian Connection,
the Seventh Day Adventists, they've all
come.
>> Mhm. Those that stood for the truth
which they had discovered or who
retained them in their ranks were bound
and persecuted and massacred. If you
discovered new truth, those that had
established a creed turned against them.
>> Yeah.
>> Is it going to happen?
>> It's still happening.
>> Still happening. But not one of these
truths fell to the ground. They're all
there.
>> Yeah. So even though it looked, he
looked back and he said, "Oh, it still
kept on."
>> Yeah. They were burnt at the stake. But
is the doctrine gone?
>> Nope.
>> No. They were all gathered into the
jewel case of God to resurface again and
again until they were woven into the
fabric of truth that forms part of the
last message of mercy to humanity. So
what all of these people had discovered,
Martin, it's alive and well.
And I'm going to be
so arrogant as to say that the only
place where all of these doctrines are
present is when the within the 7th day
Adventist church.
>> Well, they can prove try and prove you
wrong.
>> They can try and prove me wrong.
>> Yeah.
>> But a qualifier, the sad point is that
the members of that church are snoring.
>> That's a thing. So you don't qualify if
this is true by the members. You qualify
by the doctrine.
>> Correct. So they've made a pillow of the
doctrine. They've put it on their bed
and they're snoozing on them instead of
shouting them from the walls of Zion.
So with these truths in right settings,
the character of God stands vindicated
against the plethora of lies that Satan
has fabricated.
The vindictive doctrines of eternal hell
>> that make God a monster.
>> Yeah.
The immortality of the soul which God
swept away in the very first words. The
day you eat of it, you will surely die.
Doesn't mean live eternally.
the doctrine of purgatory
works mortification.
>> All of those things, Calvinistic,
arbitrary predestination,
all of these make God a monster.
>> Yeah.
>> And many others stand exposed for what
they are. Blasphemous attacks on the
character of God.
Martin, this is the issue, the character
of God. What God are you waiting for?
Millions have turned atheists or
infidels because of doctrines such as
these and the churches have an awful
record to face in the judgment.
>> It is not as though they were left
without warning, but they stubbidly
clung to vicious creeds and would
persecute those who tried to inform
them.
>> And it's still exactly the same today.
>> They still do the same. You like we
mentioned the lesser of two evils.
>> Yes. Yes, it's not it's bad if it
happens to you, but it's not as bad as
for the common good.
>> So, let us not despise the truth just
because it does not find acceptance by
the world's great men or because it was
often proclaimed by humble men who had
not been educated in the great centers
of learning. Zechariah says, "For who
has despised the day of small things?"
That's a beautiful way of putting it.
For they shall rejoice and shall see the
plummet in the hand of Zerubbabel with
those seven. They are the eyes of the
Lord which run to and fro through the
whole earth. Then answered I. And I said
unto him, who are these two olive trees
upon the right side of the candlestick,
and upon the left side thereof?
And I answered again and said unto him,
"What be these two olive bronzes which
through the golden pipes empty the
golden oil out of themselves?" And he
answered unto me and said, "No, thou not
what these be?"
And I said, "No, my Lord." Then he said,
"These are the two anointed ones that
stand by the Lord of the whole earth."
So there we have the Bible. We have the
two anointed ones, the Old and the New
Testament, the gospel in type and the
gospel in verity.
And every single prophecy has been
fulfilled except for the final cherry on
top
>> which they are meticulously placing on
their cake
right now.
>> Yeah. Busy as we speak.
>> Yeah. As Luther took his stand on the
scripture, the proud Ek retorted,
"I am surprised at the humility and
modesty with which the reverent doctor
undertakes to oppose alone so many
illustrious fathers and pretends to know
more than the sovereign pontiffs,
councils, and doctors and universities."
That sounds so familiar. [laughter]
It's fascinating how history repeats
itself and as this pope as you said has
just said anybody who believes this book
is a is a bane to society.
>> It would be surprising no doubt if God
had hidden the truth from so many saints
and martyrs until the advent of the
reverend father.
So here you have Martin Luther and who
are these so many saints and all these
enlightened ones. It's the Thomas Ainus
who says it's fine to steal if you have
need. And by the way, steal for your
buddy while you're at it.
>> Exactly. Well, you can see that
everywhere now.
>> That's becoming very popular. [laughter]
>> Oh, Martin, history is fascinating. So,
the tendency of humanity is to seek the
wisdom of man over the wisdom of God.
But God says, "Cease ye from man
whose breath is in his nostrils. For
when wherein is he to be accounted of?"
Some of the worldly churches have given
up the blessed hope. They're building an
earthly empire.
They've just had this beautiful
Abrahamic accord.
[laughter]
>> Let's leave Christ out of it. Let's go
back.
>> What was those things? We having all
these wonderful gettogethers and uh
religious meetings and all of these
things, but Christ, we can name his name
Jesus, but that's where it stays.
>> That's where it stays. Yeah. They're
preparing to set up a kingdom on earth
where they will rule for a thousand
years while they turn their backs on
Christ and his kingdom.
The kingdom of Christ is prepared for
the children of the first resurrection
and the translated living and they
possess it forever and ever. It will not
be left to the children of disobedience
but Christ will set it up. This is the
conflict.
>> We are right there.
In the days of these kings, says Daniel,
shall the God of heaven set up a kingdom
that shall never be destroyed. And the
kingdom shall not be left to other
people.
>> It shall break in pieces and consume all
these kingdoms. And it shall stand
forever. Martin the second beast of
Revelation is saying I'm going to do it.
>> Yeah.
>> And
>> and everybody is shouting hallelujah.
>> And the 10 horns are shouting
hallelujah. And the little horn is
shouting set aside your doctrines and
forget these fundamentalists.
>> Yeah. We have to be brother brotherly
love. But we forget about God. God's
love to God.
>> Correct. Hosea says, "You have plowed
wickedness. You have reaped iniquity.
You have eaten the fruit of lies because
thou did not trust in thy way and the
multitude of thy mighty men." So they
will go that same road.
>> What is that saying? Um Ephraim
is bound.
>> He's bound to idols. Let him go. Let him
go.
So the phrase wide awake, Martin, is
used 630 times in the spirit of
prophecy. Did you know that?
>> No, I didn't. But
>> so now is the time when we should be
wide awake and not slumbering as though
we had no hope or were unaware of the
times that we are living in.
>> Be sober. Be vigilant. Your adversary,
the devil, is a roaring lion and he's
walking about and he wants to devour
you. You know that's also this is also a
fulfillment of prophecy. The snoring.
>> Of course [laughter]
>> all the virgins were sleeping.
>> All of them. But that really is quite
disconcerting because it means we're
sleeping too.
>> Mhm. You remember you did one that said
over in the overwhelming surprise.
>> Yes. And then you mentioned in there
that all the disciples ran and we even
mentioned that if all these things
really start to happen, we might also
want to run for a while. Prepare
yourself. Prepare steal yourself. So the
kingdoms of this world have not yet
become the kingdoms of our Lord. This
comes to from councils to parents and
teachers.
It's not yet the kingdom of our Lord. He
hasn't allowed it for 2,000 years.
and of his Christ.
Do not deceive yourselves. Be wide awake
and move rapidly, for the night cometh
in which no man can work. Do not
encourage students who come to you
burdened with the work of saving their
fellow men to enter upon course after
course of study.
>> All of these long courses, that's why
we've introduced short evangelistic
courses. Do not lengthen out the many
years to many years the time for
obtaining an education. By so doing you
give them the impression that there is
time enough and this very plan proves a
snare to their souls.
>> Okay. So if somebody tells you yeah but
when she wrote this 100 years has
already passed. So what why couldn't
they do the studying then? I think you
get the answer right there. This very
plan proves a snare to their souls. So
correct that long studying is not
because it was for themselves as well
because that long studying can
extinguish the fire.
>> Exactly. And Martin if you had kept a
pace with the events as they are
unfolding in the book of revelation
then you would also have a better idea
of where you are standing in the stream
of time
>> and it can keep you awake wide awake.
So, the kingdom will never
[clears throat] be returned to earthly
powers. Never. It will be swept away. It
will be dust. It will be gone.
Nor will the church Christian church
rule again in this phase that they are
in of ecommenism.
It has been given to Christ as his
right. For he is king of kings and lord
of lords. The word of the Lord through
Ezekiel addressing the last king of
Judah was the following.
And thou profane wicked prince of
Israel.
>> That's Zedekiah, right?
Whose days come when iniquity shall have
an end. Thus says the Lord God, remove
the diadem.
Take away the crown.
>> Take off the crown. This shall not be
the same. Exalt him that is low and
abase him that is high. I will overturn
overturn overturn it and it shall be no
more until he comes whose right it is
and I will give it to him.
>> Why did Ezekiel use the term overturn
over three times?
>> That's a very good question, Martin. We
should think about that a little bit. So
where was it overturned? It was
overturned when it was taken away the
kingdom from the children of Israel.
Right. Then it was overturned and it was
given to Christ. He was crowned king.
>> Yeah.
>> He was the king. Then came the papacy.
>> Mhm.
>> And they claimed the crown for
themselves. Remember the crowns were on
the horns.
>> Yeah.
>> And the little little horn was being
prescriptive to all the kings.
>> Mhm.
>> So it was overturned then. Now they're
trying to set it up again. is going to
be overturned again
>> three times.
>> Yes.
>> So, three times they're going to do
this. We're now in the stage where the
crowns are not there,
>> but then they'll give power unto the
beast for this little while at the end
and he'll have his crown back.
>> Yeah.
>> And then it's going to be overturned
finally. That's the third time. I don't
know whether that's correct, but uh
that's
>> makes sense.
>> Reasonable assumption, I believe.
>> Yeah.
>> And it won't be anymore. It's got to
belong to Christ.
>> That's it. That's the um image of Daniel
taken away by the stone that's not been
carved out by any hands of men.
>> No. And Micah says, "And thou tower of
the flock, the stronghold of the
daughter of Zion, unto thee shall it
come, even the first dominion,
the kingdom shall come to the daughter
of Jerusalem."
Christ is going to set it up and his
subjects will be the heirs. They will
not do it. And I will make him my
firstborn, says Psalms 89, higher than
the kings of the earth. My mercy will I
keep for him forever more, and my
covenant shall stand fast with him. His
seed also will I make to endure forever,
and his throne as the days of heaven.
Martin, the heirs of the kingdom will be
those that will be resurrected at his
coming
>> and those that will be translated. Yeah.
>> He who testifies these things says
surely I come quickly. Amen. So come
Lord Jesus. Martin come Lord Jesus.
Everything has been fulfilled.
>> Amen.
So this throne
is some earthly pontificate going to sit
on it.
>> No, I'm very glad. No,
>> no. This throne is reserved.
>> Yeah.
>> For the king of kings and lord of lords
where the earthly kingdoms have been
overturned, overturned, overturned
and he will be the one to set up the
kingdom. So, Martin,
time's up.
>> Ready or not,
>> here I come.
>> Yeah,
>> that's what he's saying. And that's what
we should be wide awake to. Amen. Wide
awake. Let's pray.
>> Heavenly Father,
everything has been fulfilled except the
final cherry on top of which they are
busy with partaking of and placing it
where they want it.
And then comes sudden destruction.
Lord, help us to spread the word and to
call a people out of Babylon which has
become a house of demons and every
unclean and hateful bird resides there.
Help us to bring the light to the world
that they may accept the light which
emanates from the son of God who will
sit on that throne. In Jesus' name I
pray. Amen. I am
[music]